[موسيقى]
حياكم الله بالخير
قبل ابدا ودي تساعدوني بشغله حدث مثل هذا
ما يقوم بيوم الليله وراه شباب وبنات
دكاتره قاموا عليه ودي تساعدوني اننا
نعطيهم تحيه على اهل الجهد اللي سووا
الشباب الله يعطيهم العافيه قالوا نحتاج
جمله نعرف فيها عن انت وش تبغى تقول للناس
وش الشي اللي جاي تقوله والصدق جات في
بالي جملتين جمله فيها من الايجابيه الشيء
الكثير اللي هي بوابه مجلس جدك بوابتك
للعالم
وشيء فيه مدري بس ممكن يسوداويه شوي اللي
هو
وش بتخسر اذا توفى جدك شو بتخسر اذا ما
عرفت مجلس جدك
يعطيكم العافيه
[تصفيق]
طيب
فهذه السالفه اللي ما احب كانت واضحه في
البدايه بس اخترنا الايجابيه الايجابيه
مطلب في الحياه فقلنا باب مجلس ستك للحياه
البدايه كانت من سالفه في مجلس جدتي كانت
تقول هذاك اليوم خالك كان صغير وانا
مشغوله في المزرعه ازرع واحصد واشتغل فيها
حطيت خالك عند الشجره وقمت في امور
المزرعه جتني صديقتي ام فلان البدويه
وجلسنا ناخذ ونعطي
خاله يبكي انا ما انتبهت لانه مشغول عنه
صديقتي شدها المنظر هي تقوله وقالت ما على
الدنيا مريح ولد الحضر حضر القشع يصيح
يعني هذه كانها رموز صاحب الواحد يفهمها
وشو القش وكيف انت ما انت بدويه وحياتك
بالراعي والزراعه هذه السياقات كان صعبه
افهمها من اليوم الاول ابن خلدون يقول
تقرا له البدو والحظر علاقتهم ما هي
متكامله فلا بيت الشعر مثل المزرعه ولا
المزرعه مثل الناقه بس كان هذاك الشاعر
عنده راي ثاني اللي يقول البدو اللي
بالقرا نازلينا كلنا عطاه الله من هبه
الريح
مختلفه
الدائم وجه الله ولا باقي الا هو القدر
انه اصحاب هذول المجالس يتوفون او في
حالتي توفت جدتي وش تقدر تسوي هل تقعد كتف
اياديك ما اتوقع انه حل الحل انك تفتش على
الناس عندهم مثل هذه القصص وهذا اللي صار
فتشت حولي ولقيت ابو ضيف ابو ضيف رجال من
اهل محافظه مراد يقول حافظت على دكان ابوي
وعمي اللي اعمارهم 70 سنه اعمار هذه
الدكاكين عشان الجيل الجديد يشوف شلون
كانوا اباءه واجداد عليه
والصدق مفهوم الدكان غريب ان تدخل محل
يبيع صدام ددسن ويبيع كريم اطفال يبيع كل
شيء تحت سقف واحد
اخذنا جوله يعني في هذا الدكان وشد عيني
دفتر احمر
هذا هو الدفتر عوامل التعريه واضحه فيه
تحس السنين داخل هذا الدفتر وضيف هذا وشو
قال هذا دفتر الحسابات اصحاب القريه اليوم
ما عنده يدفع بكره ما عنده بكره يدفع
الشهر الجاي قبل ما نتصفح هذا الدفتر كان
فيه جمله
ومشطوب عليها مكتوب يلغى هذا الدين على
فلان الفلاني يضيق حالته الماديه في هذاك
الدكان عرفت ان هذه حارتنا هذولا اهلنا
هذا ابوي يجدي لانه ما بعد شفتهم
في احد منكم قد صحى من الحر
طفوا عليهم
مهدي
مهدي يقول لي شهر الماضي المكيف كان خربان
بس عاد ندري يعني ما يرد علي الحين المهم
هذا صار معنا في الربع الخالي
كنا في زياره لمجلس فضل ابو الثقيل فضل
يعيش في الربع الخالي لاكثر من اربع سنوات
وحيدا ما عندها احد وانا قلت طوال اربع
سنوات يعني حتى العيد يمر هو لحاله رمضان
يمر هو الحاله كان عنده في رمضان ذاك
اليوم تسحرنا صلينا الفجر نمله صحينا تسعه
الصباح حر وعجاج انا ما ادري شلون صابر
واتوقع فضله اكثر انسان على سالبته في
حياتي فشلون تاكل شلون تقضي يومك كيف شلون
ايش وحده كانت من الاسئله اللي
اتوقع اعطتني نظره ثانيه لهذه الحياه فظل
شلون تحس السعاده
فضل قال خليك سمح اذا كنت سمح تشوف الدنيا
سمحه
سمحه هذه انا مرت علي جدتي كانت تقول ودي
بسمح البال لو ما معه مال يعل كثر المال
الوارثين انا عرفتها بالذكر في مجلس الجده
بس عرفتها حق وحقيقه في مجلس فضل هذه
جلستنا كانت مع فضل مفترسين الارض وتلحفين
السماء
نتقهوى هالقهوه يعني تشوفون الظلام الدامس
ما ورانا شيء أذكر المفضل التفت عليه مؤشر
على الظلام قال الله شايفين النعمه دي
خفنا انه يشوف جني حنا ما نشوفه كنا لا
والله ما احنا الله يعافيك بالنسبه الهواء
دي ما انتم شايفينها اه انت استشعر حتى
نسمه الهوى انها نعمه
وحنا في طائر الربع الخالي وطاير البر زين
اخذنا رحله مع قريان الهاجري قريان من اهل
المنطقه الشرقيه
اشتغل في شركه تنقيب عن النفط وعمره ذاك
اليوم 14 سنه بس لما وصل 18 اشتغل مع
ارامكو لان ارامكو ما توظفت المهم
يقول بعد سنه جاني بيتر هذا مدير الامريكي
ويمشي القريان قريان بسبب الترقيه بس
بالانجليزي يقول والله ماخذها
ليه كتعطيني الترقيه وتعطي ربعي وتسمع
يقول ربعي تحس انهم خمسه سته ربع قريان
150 رجال
فقريان يوم نشتغل في اكبر شركات العالم ما
نسوا وصيه ابو جده لا تنسى ربك
هذا قريان
في
اخذنا معاه رحله ودانا الجبل وفي هذاك
الجبل مدفون جركل اسود يقول انا دفنت هذا
قلنا ليش كانوا شادين ذاك الزمان وامي حست
انه بتجيبني فطلعت من الجبل وراحت لها
المكان ولدتني تخلت على ابوي قالت يا محمد
ابشر بالرجال انت تشوف قريان انه كان هو
مهندس طرق البترول كذا جاء هذه سياقات
اهلنا
وانا احب سواليف المجالس واحب سواليف في
الاصدقاء والربع والجماعه كنا في مجلس
ابراهيم الشلاقي في حايل ابراهيم يسولف عن
ابوه يقول ابوي ذاك اليوم في دار طين في
الرجال
المضيف معه دله صغيره وثلاثه فناجيل بس هل
هو بخل حاشا لله لكن القلب والحاجه يقول
يصب للرجال فنجاني يتقهوى ياخذ الفنجان
يصبه للي بعده خلص يكب القهوه يحط فيها
سكر وشاهي ويسوي شاهي في الدله ويتقهون
حنا نسمع عن صدورنا وسيعه والقلب ما هو
بقل في القدر بس القلب من قلب الماده
والواحد يقدر يصير كريم
ويعطي من اقل الحاجات
يقول احمد الناصر من عاش بالدنيا يشوف
العجايب مثل ما شفت بالدنيا وشفتها باهلها
لو بقص القصص اللي عشناها وشفناها في هذه
المجالس ويصبح الصبح ما خلصنا بس لعلنا
يمكن نكتفي باربع قصص هذه انا تامر
السنيدي مؤسس مشروع فلان من شركه ثمانيه
كل هذه القصص مصوره
كل هذه القصص مصوره بعضها نشر بعضها للحين
حسيت ان عندي مسؤوليه ان القصص هذه ما
تجلس حبيسه هذه المجالس لازم تطلع للناس
صوت وصوره ويشوفونها
ازعم اني اسولف اسمع ازعم اني اسمع اكثر
مني اسولف فما الله اجعل لي اثنين فم واحد
عشان اسولف واجد لعلي اليوم هذا الاستثناء
اللي يثبت القاعده ان شاء الله
وعندي وصيه اخيره قبل اخلص اذا تعرف مجلس
تدور فيه سالفه تستاهل انك تسمعها احضره
الناس تروح اعمارهم في قصه في تجربه وتاخذ
حياه تادمه في سالفه احرصوا عليها
[موسيقى]
مادام هديه موجود مهدي مره جالسين على
قهوه هذه اخر سالفه اكيد يقول تدري ثامر
وش القضيه اللي ما تخسر مثل وش ابو حامد
قال الانسان ان خسرها خسر عمرها وانا اقول
القضيه اللي لازم ما تخسر هي سالفه
الانسان انسان ما عنده سالفه يقولها ما
عنده تاريخ وانسان ما عنده تاريخ ما في
مستقبل ينتظره هالكلام اللي يقول اهل
الاجتماع والتاريخ
في مجلس ابو ضيف عرفت ان الجار للجار وفي
مجلس فضل عرفت ان ودي بسمح البال لو ما مع
مال وفي مجلس قريان عرفت لا تنسى ربك وفي
مجلس ابراهيم الشلاقي عرفت ان الضيق ضيق
الاماكن ما هو الضيق نفوس وش ابغى اقول
ابغى اقول كل هذه المجالس كانت انطلاقتي
منها فنجان القهوه اخذه مع جدتي فوش بخسر
لو ما عرفت جدتي
كنت بخسر جزء من هويتي السلام عليكم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]